[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
GameSpot Krauss kind of funny here at e3
2015
I'm Greg Miller this is Jeff Gerstmann
hello that is Vernon Shaw hey I'm Vernon
Shaw name you might not know but you
probably know him as his alias hot
pepper gaming that's me
sorry everybody so you're the guy who on
youtube.com slash hot pepper gaming has
people come in and eat hot peppers yeah
and then review video games yeah and
review the pepper at the same time yeah
usually is a brilliant idea thank you
well it's there's a there's a lot
between brilliant and kind of dumb way
in torturous and gay people yeah yeah no
you do something on there usually called
you do hot pepper gaming reviews yeah
you do fire sale yeah helpers come on
eat a pepper and try to sell their game
absolutely
I thought at e3 we could do hot pepper
gaming previews yeah where I grab people
like Jeff Gerstmann headed bring him up
here and then make him eat a pepper
review the pepper in preview a game he's
seen at e3 we looking about this before
right did Dan Reicher say you said you
were all on board signed the contracts
for you it was great [ __ ] yes alright
now we have a long segment so we don't
need to jump right into it right we're
going to let you sweat it out we got
them this is the puke bucket with a puke
bucket okay this all makes more sense
now yeah we have all the peppers for the
week you're not the only one doing this
I want you to know this will all be
capped off on Thursday by devon Sawa
doing this okay from idle hands from
final destination all right if I can
blaze a trail for them selling the bar
for Devon South is this legal ish yeah I
guess we have you ever worried about
that when you go yeah we make people sit
we usually make people sign waivers okay
good but that right now you're assigning
by talking that's like okay all right I
haven't got up and run away yeah except
you're here by your own volition yours
here for the internet fame of it all
yeah totally absolutely that's that's
what I'm here always for now Jeff yes
what number III is this for you
how many of there been set I think 20 is
it 20 21 damn I think 95 was the first
one okay man since then
well 95 a 10-1 you count up well yeah 21
21 yeah
okay so yes all in all of them yeah yeah
I started team I started going to CES
before there was an e3 yeah that was
cool comes twice a year and no one
really cared about the games they were
just there to see like car stereo
speakers yeah whatever else so we could
just go off to the side and play super
nintendo games gotcha
yeah how does this one match up to what
you've seen so far I think it's an
interesting show we're in that mid
generation period where they start
actually showing games right yeah yeah
right now it's not just hardware it's
actually a this is this game looks good
like been running for a while we figured
out how to actually make things for this
thing yeah it feels like everyone's like
a year behind on some of that stuff but
I guess I think everyone got caught
off-guard when people decided they
actually still wanted consoles right yes
right I remember when we were all pretty
prognosticating yeah the final console
generation right everyone's like oh no
people still want these things so Rinat
everything get everything remake every
game it is try to feel games I think you
say that you look at PlayStation in
particular right lane the last two
holidays they've been caught with their
pants down you know absolutely order
gets bumped it now Uncharted gets bumped
it's right what do we put here how about
a God of War three remake and an
uncharted collection 30 collection yeah
this is a well put these up against halo
sure there you go well it'll go great
for everyone yeah exactly and then fall
outs like well I'm just gonna kill
everything and then Microsoft's like
well why don't we just remake yours and
want Gears War one I mean but just one
cuz ya know not all three then you can
slowly trickle those out yeah I guess if
you put all those in one package it
would be like you'd realize like oh this
is like totally the same so what I put
out that way you put out the next one
like oh man things have changed for
Gears for ya yeah and I like that they
dropped it there's just gears for ya
that like fast furious I want to like go
like read copyright information and see
if that's just their logotype or real
I've got a wiki database to run these
are things I need to know for you it is
a big it's a big to know here's four or
Gears of War 4 yeah
or Gears of four I bet they're all a
copy right they probably got a lot more
yeah yeah yeah for turning hey how's e3
been from your perspective it's been
really great actually because um every
year I've gone and I haven't been able
to go to all ye threes but every year
I've gone all of the it's always been
about like the Kinect or the move it's
always been very like look at
us waving our arms around kind of stuff
thank God now we're just wrapping
everything to our face yeah seriously
we're in the future but now it's like
hey remember stuff you like from 2007
it's back and you have disposable income
because you're older now so you should
buy all this stuff sure so I'm pretty
happy right now I'm super stoked to have
money to buy Yeah right
does VR do anything for you uh I mean I
think it's really interesting but I feel
like they haven't made the case with on
the software side of things right red
red and that was the thing like last
night at Sony there was this weird
moment where like okay they're getting
into the VR like let's go and I'm like
I'm actually halfway looking to see how
they're going to try to show it because
it seems like that's a hard problem and
then they get into it they get into the
arm like okay great okay great okay
great and then I started talking about
Spotify
and I'm like oh is like Harmonix music
VR tying into spot like oh no they're
just done talking about VR we waited in
20 seconds yeah Morpheus like I ate it
so bad because I bet Colin it was going
to be 20 minutes or more right I thought
this is they were going to come out
they're gonna make the case there's
gonna be thing when they did the pan
back for the guerilla game whose name
honored no rice or rice zero dawn
horizon and they did it and they went
from the little screen and then headed
filthy I'm like they're gonna announces
the Morpheus game right and then no and
then I was like they're gonna announce
everything the Morpheus game yeah no
they're gonna do two minutes and never
talk about it not only to do that they
then got up there and said like hey this
thing's optional yeah like they tried to
step away from it and say like you know
this is the thing we're doing you'll
need to have it like they're scared of
their own VR which is nice because when
they when they first started talking
about it a few GD C's ago right they
were like we're not even sure if we will
bring this to market right and then this
past GDC they're like we're bringing it
to market and then this year you figure
if there's you know Adam was on one of
our interviews today
yeah instead still the first half of
2016 so this is their last e3 yeah I
guess I mean I know they're showing
stuff here right as I would have figured
it would have impacted the press
conference exactly because you need to
sell to the mainstream right you need to
make people aware that this is come yeah
but I think the only way to sell to the
mainstream is to get it in there and get
it on their faces yeah so it's like you
know they did that Vita Lounge thing
yeah I have to imagine if not them then
oculus not not them than HTC right what
do pop-up shops or like hey we're in
Best Buy forever yeah doing
demos because it's you know it's
impossible to explain that to someone in
a way that I think can truly convey what
you're actually seeing yeah when you
strap that thing on right like you have
to put it on your face go oh okay and
what they're doing now it makes sense
yeah I want to get one of these things
yeah yeah so yeah it's gonna make it
really hard to sell totally you know
like how do you are you interested in VR
other than like your disposable income
oh no III do enjoy the fact that we're
living in the future it feels like V
ours at that point where like early film
ones where it's like oh man look at
these people just kind of going about
their day you got the 360 view of them
all it's it's kind of boring yeah in
maybe five years is gonna get really
wild it's gonna get really innovative
but right now I think we're in that
formative period of VR where there's
kind of boring stuff out there and the
real innovation is going to start a
little bit further in the future yeah
let's hope I if it just becomes every
first person game that they make is
suddenly a VR thing right that's a
little disappointing right I mean it has
to be something new as to kind of
transcend existing games and that's the
whole thing like the games are showing
here they aren't Uncharted they aren't
gorilla they are these guys who you need
on board to push now you can make the
argument that would voice off Media
Molecule right maybe dreams is a
Morpheus game I get me back doing this
and making weird-ass legs for this
creepy ass puppet yeah but even that
like you're not saying that and that
game is already abstract enough so to
make it so much more it's like at some
point you get lost right I actually
would have figured that would have been
the time for them to say oh by the way
no man's sky yeah more hey yeah you know
like but they look like they have more
than enough on their plate to keep them
busy and beaten down to just get that
game done at all yes yeah maybe that's
just yeah when no man's sky was out I
was like great we're finally gonna so
we're back and we're seeing how big
spaces
yeah we're exploring the woods like what
is this game about what hell happens I
just gave I thought that maybe that demo
that demo seemed like it was almost
being done against their will it was
like it's sort of like all right some
people wanna see what you wanna do fine
here you go you shoot stuff I'm shooting
stuff now I'm gonna land on this planet
with a gun and look at me I'm shooting
stuff there it's a video game
leave me alone let me get back my buddy
finish finish this thing ah this is keep
flooding yeah exactly
uh-uh yeah that was kind of how that
demo read to me is like look fine there
are guns okay
leave me alone yeah I'm gonna go finish
this out you also said there you could
fight right if there's hail eh I don't
know it's tough yeah what do you want to
do what do you want to do in this
alright so Jeff what do you want to
preview for hot pepper gaming III well
I've got a couple of things that I've
seen today that I could talk about one
is a game another is an experience so I
don't know if you've heard about this
stuff yeah I mean my choices
alright so uh need for speed okay which
I played the game it's a video game and
the hololens experience that was created
to kind of show people what the new mode
in Halo 5 was all about oh I don't know
man we're kind of in the year of like
the weird experiences I think you gotta
go hololens and tell me about this halo
5 is okay yeah all right now Vernon okay
people are joining us for the hot
peppers yeah explain again hot pepper
gaming what do we need what do we do
with all the peppers so for how pepper
gaming the the it's a very simple
concept all people do is a try to review
a video game directly after eating a hot
pepper and we review the the video game
in the hot pepper at the same time I
don't know if you know but hot peppers
kind of hurt okay so the comedic crux of
it all right trying to say something but
also not intersection between
consumables and ya know you can make an
argument about it being a strange like
sarcastic lampooning and video games
industry it's not it's just it's just
dumb stupid fun I like a lot actually
how many how many people have taken I've
done this okay we have a little over I
think 120 episodes okay so we've been
doing we're coming up on our two-year
anniversary how many subs do you have uh
225,000 sons of [ __ ] watching other
people's misery yeah it's a yeah yeah I
did not think it would get this big yeah
everyone myself and everyone who works
on the channel we have a we have a lot
of fun doing it and before this we were
kind of just like fans of the video game
industry and now it's just awesome to
like get to hang out with the people
like we really respect and really want
to work with so it isn't okay it is an
honor to torture you is we're trying to
say alright
well when you started down this path did
you expect it to blow up or we're going
to be like you for and that was it no I
mean we uh when we did it we were like
oh man it's going to take a while for
this to get big let's just keep
stockpiling episodes and maybe one day
someone will find out about this and
like it but from the first episode it
got pretty big and you know like we got
a couple features from a lot of amazing
amazing publications there was a big
giant bomb for foreign posts about you
and me yeah yeah that it was just so
awesome to read and um it sort of
started started making rounds and like
people who again I really respected they
they started messaging me like hey can
we do this and and it I am never not
sort of like gobsmacked at like how
strange of a thing this is and how big
it's gotten so it really really is an
honor to be here all right cool
so the rules are he's gonna eat the
pepper yep he'll review the pepper after
eating it okay he's gonna tell you about
hololens before it absolutely thank you
doesn't have to tell me specifically
okay that's the mean you're talking to a
light pole cam talk to that light pole
okay that one right there hello this one
here yeah that one right there unless
you want to go ahead okay all right talk
to this under this one heat oh okay
we're not that one which one that one
but none of the other calculation I'm at
PlayStation turn off your TV you're
distracting us so you leave that uh
don't touch your eyes okay average all
right we're going any of the milk until
you're done yeah and you're gonna let
you decide right should we choose a
pepper right now just to sort of but
yeah yeah you're you're you're the pro
you go through and pick one I'll get
I'll get a milk poured shedding it's not
gonna mean one oh yeah
yeah all right oh don't uh Nick scarpino
a veteran of hot pepper gaming for kind
of funny is buzzing in right now my ear
and saying don't touch your penis either
yeah so wash your hand man before you
touch your eyes or your penis and I'll
guarantee you two out onto that I mean
you got you got a you got a oh yeah oh
yeah give give them assuming that way
yeah that's what we're going with now
what makes that one meaner than the
others when you look at a pepper note
the opaque orange
a skin tone very healthy very ripe um
your your you're gonna you're gonna have
a fun time with this one my friend okay
so I eat the pepper I talked to you
about hololens and the pepper ya know at
then you just give the pepper score it's
always five out of five yeah spoilers
yeah sorry to give away the truth no
because people people have like I've
said that every time we've done a review
and it's gotten to the point where
people just stop listening to me
yeah and I don't blame them because it's
a lot going through the brain by the
time yeah and also hey Colin Colin can
we get paper towels or napkins we've
done this before we know it's about we
have everybody I have a few but I have a
few napkins in my bag if needed
so that's your puke bucket has anyone
ever puked never during the review never
during the review let's beat that right
now with Jeff Dorson
okay so what you're gonna do you can eat
everything but the little green stem and
the little green stem pops off okay um
so have you eaten anything today
uh let's see I had a little bit of kind
of crappy breakfast out of a tray
there's a little bit of bacon okay
you're gonna want to like sandwich this
thing with food okay like okay looking
out for your personal health and
well-being okay you might not know this
but the same sort of I'll hold okay all
right hold all this for you the same
sort of mucus membranes that exists in
your mouth are also sort of in your butt
so this is a definite like double end
experience great sad several hours apart
yeah thanks for the loose there's
there's no pretty great there's no
pretty way to say this um so just go
ahead and eat it chew it a bunch swallow
it like you don't want to like swallow
the whole thing because then it'll give
you a really bad stomach ache just give
it a bunch of [ __ ] just take it on the
chin
take it up front yeah it up it's gonna
it'll hurt more but now but it'll hurt
less
later if that makes sense okay um yeah
Wow um when you sorry we can drink the
milk don't chug it swish it around your
mouth there we go little sips alright
okay okay alright if you have like tums
or pepcid ac that's where you go I've
been working on it if I have to like
weird I didn't bring any of those my
hotel room will get alright okay oh you
came prepared all right I'm gonna give
this to you everybody around to applause
or Jeff Gerstmann as he gets
ready for the first-ever gamespot cross
kind of funny hot pepper gaming so it'll
be 3 2015 preview it'll pop right out
yes that will just pop right out chew it
up and go yeah I'm really quick there's
a tiny bit of an intro you just say hey
I'm deaf in front of giantbomb today I'm
going to be giving a preview of the
hololens technology ok but first i'm
gonna eat a hot pepper okay hello my
name is Jeff Gerstmann from Giant Bomb
I'm going to do a hot pepper preview of
the hololens technology demo shown at e3
but for the first I'm going to eat this
pepper yep
it's very hot yep I'm not sure I could
pull this you got to believe you got the
bucket you got the bucket
Jeff jannett Jeff Jeff Jeff okay
I haven't swallowed anything yet but
it's ready to start dogging you can but
it's just going to hurt more
alright hallo Jeff eh
[Music]
she's got to believe in yourself get in
there you all have to believe yeah okay
yeah so they did a demo for this new
mode called war zone
for Halo 5 it's their cut um Unai and
other people and they let us put on the
hololens first they had to measure the
distance between our eyes too for the
hololens i'm a 65 here between my eyes
and they put it on your head and then
like it's a tiny square in the middle
it's not peripheral and they show you
like halo waypoints you get up and walk
around and you go and they get you that
you they lead to this table and on the
table there's a smarten lady and she
tells you about the warzone mode then
you can look around at the ship and
it'll show you different different stuff
on the ship like look at this rocket
it's if we're making the ship go this is
a gun and then they walk you through the
mode they zoom in on the map I was
actually surprisingly stable I didn't
really bounce around on the table or
anything like that it was pretty good
but it was only like a small part in the
center not peripheral so I had to kind
of lean back to see it all and my nose
is starting to run and then they kind of
walked through that for five minutes or
so they said hey pick up a comm ship and
you look down there's like a USB stick
and then but next to it was a little
light-up thing in the Holland we said
hey get this comp so I got the cop chip
and walked in and played halo 5 warzone
mode which is like I don't know it's
some number of players versus some
number are there other players but a
bunch of a I and their two bases you got
to kill the AI get a thousand points and
we lost miserably we did terribly they
kicked our ass
this pepper is really hot it took me a
really long time to swallow it and
there's still little bits and pieces in
my mouth
that's probably no good right the time
to battle is great you're great okay and
that was a that was pretty much the demo
and I thought maybe they would have had
the elite controllers there because its
halo and that's the game they care about
you know but it was just a regular Xbox
one controller we lost miserably this
pepper is incredibly hot my throat hurts
a whole bunch but my mouth hurts less
than it did before and it can we give me
the Moke now it just keeps coming he
doesn't have to say how so hololens how
many out of five peppers how many
peppers how many peppers out of five is
hollow look yeah I'm gonna say like a
before is out of five okay and the
pepper the peppers are five out of love
okay big come on right over pause Jeff
Gerstmann a go there you go good man
good man Giant Bomb calm of course
follow him on Twitter
Jeff I want you to know that you look
like you're sweating from everywhere I
don't need a lot of spicy food it's like
it's like your whole body is crying
that's usually the reaction right yeah
yeah the last one I did it I everything
evaluated you turned you're a little bit
redder than usual I want you to know ya
know I'm a it's a familial my whole
family gets red with any yeah we thought
up against already I got one and the
person who was doing it just kind of
like disappeared into it
hey look what we got hums hey there you
go through the end sponsored Tom since
that now you go to the pole cam there
you go there you go
how you feeling you feeling better it's
getting there still working a little bit
swish it around in your mouth yeah great
yeah okay good uh any better than Tim
yeah yeah Tim saw the light Tim's the
gold standard yes
Collin screaming that was always one of
the highlights oh yeah we get gifts
about that I think I need to gargle yeah
that makes him free yeah spit in the
bucket if you want we got a kid we got a
kid to go throw it away hey God Ian's
yeah oh yeah you know more ya know if
there's anything I love it's room
temperature milk it's not is it real
temperature its I wouldn't call it cold
okay
it's chilled to me you're looking at
that full fat vitamin D male that's what
you got to do right you told me so how
quickly did you learn all the different
things you need to do forever at this
point I must have done a master's degree
worth of research into hot peppers yeah
but yeah it started off in the very
first one I ate a serrano pepper to test
it out and no one ever saw that video
actually just because it wasn't hot
enough and like it was just me going
like we need to go hotter man we need to
go on and try you two serrano pepper and
then a habanero pepper and then I had
the soupy gut feeling for the entire
night
it's no good can't do peppers
back-to-back like that no no no
absolutely and we're just like upping
the ante like there's a weird arms race
going on I've done I've done yeah keep
it coming man
I love milk I've been to Carolina
Reapers at this point I the hot is
commercially available pepper yeah Oh
miserably yeah yeah no I just know I've
done three at this point Wow holy wow
that is what I'm doing with my life now
have doctors tried to stop you or your
family from doing these uh no actually
uh we've looked into it a lot because I
I like most people don't want to kill
anybody
yeah um and apparently there's a there's
this more health benefits to hot peppers
and like negatives so if you have a
pre-existing condition like a stomach
ulcer or a heart condition probably
shouldn't do on peppers we should have
asked you that um I think I'm okay yeah
yeah but uh but otherwise I think I'm
that's good want will know the road I'm
on him you're going to want to switch to
water in a bit just so you don't fill
your stomach with milk B is it some
peppers are strangely actually pretty
good for you so you're super healthy no
no no it's not at all but I I put a lot
of other junk food in my body so what's
the end goal for you and hot pepper
gaming do you ever I mean like it's one
of those I do keep evolving the product
like it was interesting when you started
doing that like you know tomorrow we
have the Mega Man legacy guys coming in
yeah they're gonna do a fire sale for
that game oh there we go so it's like
what using is gonna keep making
different things like we want it we want
to make the I mean naturally we don't
want to feed people hot peppers for the
rest of our lives sugar like everyone
who works on the channel myself Jared
and we have our own things going on we
like hop every game is sort of an
ancillary to that but you know we always
want to go bigger and better with this
we're working on a format called hot
pepper versus where two players two
peppers playing a versus video game like
Street Fighter or something like that
that's cool and then the winner gets the
milk
well Vernon that is awesome everybody
subscribe to youtube.com slash hot
pepper gaming well thank you Jeff for
doing that with us anytime
everybody go to Giant Bomb com hit them
up of course keep coming to youtube.com
slash kind of funny stay on gamespot
[Music]